madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
en corse la justice accentue son enquête
sur l'état major de la gendarmerie étant
de rechercher les mobiles après la mise
en examen du colonel mazères et des
trois hommes du gps le soutien de la
france à l'albanie avec l'arrivée ce
matin à tirana de lionel jospin qui
propose une aide économique et
humanitaire supplémentaire lionel jospin
qui sera en macédoine ce soir la grève à
la sncf des perturbations plus
importantes que prévu à l'origine des
moules du mouvement des agents de
conduite autonome qui rejettent l'accord
sur les 35 heures que la direction
envisage de suspendre depuis musique
avec la tournée en france de yann
tiersen passant du violon à l'accordéon
au piano le talent de ce jeune
compositeur qui sort un nouvel album
ouvrons ce journal avec le procès des
quatre hooligans ce qu'ils ont
sauvagement agressé le gendarme daniel
nivel lors du mondial en juin 98
la première audience devant la cour
d'assises de l'essonne en allemagne se
dérouler aujourd'hui une audience au
cours de laquelle l'un des quatre
accusés passé aux aveux
le chancelier helmut kohl à l'époque
avait parlé de honte nationale pour son
pays olivier lerner ils ont enlevé leurs
boucles d'oreilles sur les crâne rasé
les cheveux ont repoussé quatre
hooligans répondent de tentative de
meurtre sur daniel nivel le plus
dangereux le plus violent c'est lui
christopher ross avec un panneau
publicitaire il a frappé le gendarme
tous avaient déjà un passé judiciaire
très chargé il est possible qu
effectivement
on est dans cette affaire des
condamnations particulièrement lourde
les peines encourues habituellement en
matière de tentative de meurtre sont de
15 ans mais jaillir sur le plan purement
théorique il est possible d'aller au
delà des gendarmes français viendront
témoigner
mathieu ce jeune lensois de 10 ans a
tous vu ce 21 juin 98
son récit est très précieux des fleurs
tricolore dans la foule qui se presse
pour voir entendre et comprendre le
geste des eaux liga
ils ont changé d'état d'esprit ils vont
s'exprimer aujourd'hui pour s'excuser
pour des pardon à la famille nivelles le
salut nazi
des propos racistes antisémites créer la
panique déclenché des bagarres générales
dans les stades en allemagne les goûts
ligan sont bien visibles
mais aujourd'hui au tribunal les femmes
des prévenus sont en pleurs et les mains
des casseurs ne peuvent plus que tapoter
un bureau en bois
les juges disposent de clichés accablant
pris sur le vif les spécialistes du
droit pénal bien connu à essen pour leur
professionnalisme
la foule des grands jours mais daniel
nivel reste invisible tout doucement il
réapprend à vivre mais il a perdu sa
mémoire
il ne s'est peut être pas que le procès
de ses agresseurs a commencé si la d4
reagan s'était passé aux aveux ce matin
il n'est pas dit que les trois autres
reconnaissent leur participation à cette
agression le premier oligan qui a frappé
daniel nivel à la tête et toujours en
fuite alors pour échapper à une peine de
dix ou quinze ans de prison ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui dans le box des accusés
vont sans doute chargé sans état d'âme
le grand absent de ce procès en corse
après la mise en examen du commandant de
la gendarmerie et deux troisièmes du gps
la justice s'interroge sur les mobiles
réels de cette opération ratée ce soir
l'enquêté s'oriente vers l'état-major de
la gendarmerie
alors qu'on commence à comprendre un peu
mieux ce qui aurait pu être à l'origine
de cette mission michele finn france
bailleur c'est peut-être le simple coup
de fil d'un policier qui a tout
déclenché une intervention d'yves
bertrand le directeur central des
renseignements généraux avril 99
bernard bonnet se lance dans la guerre
des paillotes le préfet a décidé de
faire raser ces petits restaurants
bâties illégalement sur le domaine
public maritime
le patron des rg téléphone alors en
personne à bernard bonnet il lui demande
de bien vouloir épargner l'une des
paillotes au bout du golfe d'ajaccio
le restaurant chez francis est un lieu
fréquenté par de nombreuses
personnalités îles féroe le patron est
l'un de ceux qui se battent avec le plus
de conviction et le plus d'énergie
contre la décision du préfet il a
mobilisé tous ses amis mais aujourd'hui
il dit tout ignorer de l'intervention du
directeur des rg je sais pas ce que je
connais pas
et s'il a fait ça c'est gentil de sa
part parce que le demain j'arrive pas à
reconstruire
je suis à la ruine selon certaines
sources le préfet bonnet lui n'aurait
pas apprécié l'intervention du directeur
des renseignements généraux et gendarmes
non plus c'est peut-être la
signification de ce tract retrouver
paris ferro dans les décombres de son
restaurant
dans cette perspective il semble
difficile d'imaginer que les gendarmes
aient pu monter une telle opération
l'initiative sans aux ordres de leur
hiérarchie surtout sans en informer le
préfet bonnet ou son entourage
nous avons appris il ya quelques
instants l'explosion d'une bombe dans le
centre de londres
etienne leenhardt vous êtes sur place
apparemment il y aurait de nombreux
blessés
oui béatrice effectivement l'explosion
se serait produite il ya tout juste une
demi heure dans un pub un café donc du
quartier de soho qui est un quartier du
centre de londres
extrêmement fréquenté à l'heure qu'il
est puisque les britanniques s'apprêtent
à partir trois jours pour un week end
prolongé en ce week-end du 1er mai nous
ne savons pas encore bien évidemment si
cette bombe nous sommes sûrs qu'il
s'agit d'une une explosion
nous n'avons pas encore cette explosion
est due à une bombe si elle est due au
gaz
il y aurait donc 30 blessés nous avons
surtout en ciel est liée aux deux
précédentes explosions qui je vous le
rappelle ont fait une cinquantaine de
blessés
celle d'il ya quinze jours dans le
quartier de brixton celle de la semaine
dernière dans le quartier de brick lane
qui étaient deux explosions apparemment
revendiqués par des groupuscules
d'extrême droite et au nom de deux
thèses racistes
pour l'instant nous n'avons évidemment
pas beaucoup plus mais je vous rappelle
que les crayons règles donc il ya une
demi-heure et qu'il y aurait au moins 30
personnes blessées ce qui est certain
c'est que le pub à cette heure-ci de la
journée était complètement bondé
merci etienne de ces quelques précisions
en tout cas de ces premières précisions
la grève à la sncf avec des
perturbations plus importantes que prévu
aujourd'hui la direction affirme
toutefois que les retours de vacances se
rassurer et que le trafic sera à peu
près normale ce week-end à l'origine de
ce mouvement la protestation des agents
de conduite autonome contre un accord
sur les 35 heures le pdg de la sncf
louis gallois offre aux grévistes la
possibilité de retirer ce projet est mis
les lensois
d'étranges annulés et des voyageurs en
attente voilà ce que l'on risque encore
de voir demain y compris pour certains
tgv sud-est la sncf garantie seulement
les retours des stations de sports
d'hiver
les autres tgv circuleront sans problème
pour le réseau grandes lignes
suppression d'un train sur deux en
moyenne pour les régions normandie nord
pas de calais picardie champagne-ardenne
alsace lorraine est en berne
les trains express régionaux connaîtront
eux aussi les difficultés
en région parisienne le trafic sur les
lignes rer et trains de banlieue casque
fortement perturbé sauf pour paris
montparnasse par cette grève les agents
de conduite de la fgaac un syndicat
autonome entendent protester contre le
projet d'accord sur les 35 heures à la
sncf les agents sont déjà ou 35 heures
par semaine depuis 1983
il estime que l'accord proposé laurens
pol des conditions de travail moins
avantageuses qu'actuellement
qu'à cela ne tienne là répond louis
gallois président de la sncf si la
majorité des agents son but
refuse ce dispositif personnellement je
le regretterai parce que c'est un plus
pour eux et s'ils refusent ya une
alternative que je leur propose c'est le
statu quo mais la fgaac ne s'estime pas
satisfaites pour autant elle attend
maintenant de rencontrer louis gallois
de visu pour négocier on attend d'être
reçu par la direction
mais le statu quo c'est pas ça qu'on
avec l'amour on demande à ce que soient
prises en cause soient pris en compte de
certaines revendications et d'avoir un
volet spécifique agents de conduite dans
le projet d'accord d' un conflit dans
lequel cgt et cfdt se retrouve piégé les
deux fédérations comptait organiser un
référendum sur ce texte qu'elle juge
plutôt positif l on envisage maintenant
une journée d'action pour ne pas se
laisser déborder par leur bal et puis
air france la grève des personnels au
sol a été reconduite à l'unanimité ce
matin pour 24 heures
au 16e jour du mouvement de nouvelles
discussions entre la direction régionale
et l'intersyndicale cet après-midi ont
échoué l'embellie sur le front du
chômage une baisse substantielle pour le
mois de mars avec une diminution du
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi de 1,3
pour cent soit près de 38 mille chômeurs
en moins ce recul profite
essentiellement jeune et au moins de 50
ans pascal golomer après une légère
hausse en février le chômage est de
nouveau en baisse
deux millions huit cent soixante cinq
mille 900 demandeurs d'emploi ces trente
sept mille neuf cent de moins dans les
fichiers de l'anpe satisfaction
évidemment au ministère de l'emploi qui
veut voir dans cette baisse
l'effet conjugué des 35 heures et des
180 mille créations d'emplois jeunes
cette amélioration d'un tel le moral aux
français jamais en tout cas depuis vingt
ans ils n'ont été aussi confiant dans
l'avenir même si les opinions négatives
l'important corps est plutôt que
d'épargné avec des taux d'intérêt de
moins en moins élevés ils préfèrent
consommer une consommation globale en
hausse de 3% au premier trimestre avec
près de 65 milliards de francs de
produits manufacturés achetés
une aubaine pour les industriels qui
guette à présent une reprise de
l'activité économique sur les marchés
asiatiques notamment une reprise qui
commence juste à poindre son nez
suffisamment en tout cas pour que les
chefs d'entreprise retrouve un tout
petit peu le moral après avoir touché le
fond en 1998 s'agit-il d'une simple
embellie passagère
le gouvernement lui table sur un
printemps clément d'autant que la
faiblesse de l'euro face au dollar donne
pour l'instant un bon coup de pouce à
nos exportations
le conflit en yougoslavie avec la nuit
dernière l'intensification des
bombardements sur la serbie selon le
temps il s'agit d'une des opérations les
plus sévères depuis le début des frappes
et ce en raison du renfort de quelques
300 nouveaux appareils une nouvelle fois
à belgrade a été prise pour cible
françois corner
belgrade a été effectivement la nuit
dernière la cible privilégiée des avions
de l'otan
au petit jour le centre de la capitale
du causse lave offrait ce spectacle de
désolation
le quartier général de l'armée
yougoslave deux bâtiments du ministère
de la défense le siège de la police
yougoslave ainsi que cet émetteur de la
télévision publique serbe ont été
touchés après ces raids
l'otan a réaffirmé sa volonté de
s'attaquer au coeur même de la machine
militaire de slobodan milosevic
d'après le ministère yougoslave des
affaires étrangères ces bombardements
auraient fait trois morts et une
quarantaine de blessés sur place à
belgrade le témoignage de jérôme boni
ici à belgrade les habitants vivent dans
la terreur les alertes sont permanentes
et c'est la première fois que cette
erreur est véritablement justifiée dans
la mesure où des maisons civiles ont été
abattus elles font en ruine dans le
quartier devra tiare prend aux quatre
maisons étaient touchées par trois
bombes
nous avons vu les habitants de belgrade
qui regardaient les dégâts
les gens sont très choqués ils ont un
énorme sentiment d'injustice
ils me disent que en fait la serbie il
n'a jamais été aussi unis que depuis le
début des bombardements en effet à trois
kilomètres du quartier des ministères
ces baby y ont été touchées par des
bombes ou des missiles plus que des
dégâts collatéraux comme les qualifie
l'otan cela ressemble plus à une
nouvelle erreur de dire des chasseurs
bombardiers de l'alliance malgré la
destruction de cet émetteur de
télévision sur le mont aval à la rts la
télévision serbe et mais toujours
l'objectif pour l'otan c'est et de
réduire au silence le principal outil de
propagande depuis dix ans de slobodan
milosevic
cette journée de vendredi sur le plan
diplomatique marquée par la visite de
l'émissaire russe à belgrade et victor
tchernomirdine espérer d'un
rapprochement des positions avant sa
rencontre avec sa ballade milosevic
les discussions en tête à tête qui ont
duré près de six heures mais les deux
hommes devront se rencontrer une
nouvelle fois pour tenter de trouver une
solution possible jean marc et lowe's
discrétion totale ce soir à belgrade sur
les six heures d'entretiens entre
messieurs victor tchernomirdine envoyé
spécial du président russe et slobodan
milosevic le numéro un serbe leur
premier tête à tête
voilà huit jours avait donné lieu à des
communiqués carrément contradictoires
mais hier soir à son départ de moscou
monsieur tchernomirdine assurer que
cette fois ci il était porteur de
propositions concrètes pour négocier la
fin des bombardements de l'otan
suffisamment concrètes pour qu'à l'étape
de bonnes
le chancelier allemand schröder relancer
proposition de pause dans les
bombardements
à condition bien sûr qu'il y ait des
signes vérifiable de la mort ce d'un
véritable retrait militaire serbe du
kosovo
à condition aussi ce que monsieur bio c
beach se laisse convaincre par
l'émissaire russe à sa deuxième étape de
rome monsieur tchernomirdine qui
considère que l'idée d'une présence de
l'onu au kosovo est déjà agréé par les
serbes a fait un petit pas très nets
envers les positions de l'otan en
soulignant devant le premier ministre
italien monsieur d'alema que le retour
des albanais du kosovo exigeait des
garanties de sécurité
histoire de bien faire comprendre à
monsieur milosevic
on parlait force militaire et non pas
simple présence civile des nations unies
comme l'exigent les serbes prêt à
tolérer au kosovo peut-être des soldats
russes
mandaté par l'onu mais toujours pas de
forces de l'otan comme voilà huit jours
l'émissaire ou plutôt désormais le
médiateur russe n'a pas eu cet après
midi la partie facile
on ne sait pas encore si oui ou non
cette fois il aura pu trouver un
compromis avec slobodan milosevic et les
etats unis considèrent ce soir qu'ils
n'ont pas encore reçu de belgrade
d'offre sérieuse pour un règlement du
conflit c'est ce qu'a déclaré tout à
l'heure le secrétaire d'état madeleine
albright et puis on a appris que bill
clinton se rendra en début de semaine
prochaine à bruxelles afin d'évaluer les
frappes de l'otan le soutien de la
france à l'albanie c'est la
signification affiché du voyage devienne
l jospin qui est arrivé ce matin à
tirana où il a aussitôt annoncé un
nouvel effort supplémentaire aussi bien
dans le domaine humanitaire
qu'économique
le premier ministe qui est revenu sur
l'idée d'une pause humanitaire et
mettant ses doutes et ses réserves quant
à cette parenthèse dans le conflit en
yougoslavie
dorothée olliéric pascal caron
le solde albanais à temps curieux d'une
minute à l'autre l'hélicoptère de
l'armée française va atterrir avec à son
bord lionel jospin
nous sommes à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de tirana à elbasan le pc des
forces françaises dans le cadre de
l'opération humanitaire de l'otan
baptisée abri alliés une visite au pas
de course pour lionel j'ose pas dans
cette ancienne caserne albanaise ou la
semaine prochaine seront positionnés 800
militaires français
ce matin le premier ministre a rencontré
le président albanais j'ai dit au
président la république au vice-premier
ministre que avec qui j'ai eu des
entretiens chez matin et avant de vous
rejoindre que la france allait a encore
accroître son aide économique et
financière en direction d'al bass de
l'albanie et j'ai apporté des éléments
nouveaux à cet égard concrètement le
premier ministre français a promis aux
albanais 172 millions de francs
supplémentaires pour financer des
projets de développement à court et
moyen terme
lionel jospin échange encore quelques
mots avec les militaires français
travailleur luxe dans la suite de la
visite c'est le camp de réfugiés de
colonies plus d'un milliers d'albanais
du kosovo ont trouvé refuge ici pour eux
pour rencontrer le chef du gouvernement
français un immense espoir
cette femme raconte à lionel jospin
comment sa famille a été massacrée au
kosovo elle décrit toutes sortes de
scènes de torture
c'est la vérité répète t elle sans cesse
à celui qu'ils écoutent ils ont créé le
jour et où lionel jospin parle des
criminels mais il laisse ensuite une
porte ouverte aux serbes
même quand nous aurons résolu cette
crise il faudra bien aidé l'albanie
aider la macédoine aider le monténégro
les pays des balkans
pourquoi pas un jour la serbie si elle
choisit la voie pacifique la voie
démocratique et non pas la folie
suicidaire
les autorités albanaises qui ont
accueilli plus de 350 mille réfugiés sur
leur territoire mais aussi les forces de
l'otan n'ont jamais caché qu'elle espère
être payée de retour
c'est donc chose faite au moins un
premier pas avec cette visite de lionel
jospin mais beaucoup d'albanais
attendent plus encore ils rêvent d'une
forme de protectorat durable de l'otan
pour sortir leur pays de la crise l'aîné
jospin qui est arrivé il ya quelques
instants macédoine la macédoine qui
compte quelque 160 mille réfugiés selon
une dernière estimation du hcr lionel
jospin restaurant ma se donne jusqu'à
demain dit mme jusqu'à demain midi il
s'envolera après pour l'egypte
nous retrouvons en direct de skopje en
macédoine pascal douce et bon clairement
donc la macédoine est au bord de la
catastrophe humanitaire
c'est ce que déclare ce soir le ministre
de l'intérieur qui réclame une aide
substantielle pour tenir une aide
substantielle une aide humanitaire bien
sûr la plus large possible mais aussi et
surtout une aide économique pour
répondre aux conséquences directes des
frappes de l'otan parce que les deux
tiers du commerce extérieur de ce pays
étaient tournés vers la yougoslavie
alors autant vous dire que l'économie
ici est totalement paralysé on a coutume
de dire que chaque famille macédonienne
compte deux chômeurs dans ses rangs
alors lionel jospin qui est annoncé une
rallonge substantielle à l'aide directe
que la france verse déjà au budget
macédonien cette aide est bien sûr la
bienvenue
le premier ministre monsieur georges est
ce qu'ils nous disaient hier encore mon
pays est entre les mains de l'otan aux
puissances qui composent l'otan
d'assumer leur responsabilité est
d'éviter que cette région des balkans
n'explose à son tour
et puis la nuit derrière un nouvel
incident s'est produit dans le nord du
pays et cela a donc moins de 24 heures
de l'arrivée de l'année j'espère oui un
nouvel incident en ce qui concerne les
forces françaises à 10 km au nord-est de
kumanovo à une quarantaine de kilomètres
de skopje c'est le troisième incident de
ce genre en moins d'une semaine
cette fois ci c'est une roquette
antichar qui a frôlé un blindé léger
français évidemment cet incident la est
plus inquiétant encore que les autres
d'abord parce qu'il intervient vous
l'avais dit à la veille de la venue de
lionel jospin au camp du coup ma nouveau
où il va passer la soirée ce soir et le
choix de l'arn est également très
inquiétants parce qu'il s'agit d'un
lance roquette rpg un lance-roquette
portative qui est une arme de guérilla
et qui ne laisse évidemment aucun doute
sur les intentions de ses propriétaires
merci pascal douce est bon au monténégro
à présent se sont déroulées aujourd'hui
les obsèques de la deuxième victimes
civiles des frappes de l'otan dans cette
petite république qui tentent à tout
prix de rester à l'écart du conflit
benoît duquesne jean françois rime
c'est en principe la deuxième victimes
civiles de la guerre il avait 61 ans et
quatre enfants
mercredi après midi quand les
bombardements ont commencé et la cause
se mettre à l'abri dans la voiture de
son fils et c'est là qu'un éclat la
frappe
le hasard a voulu qu'ils touchent à
travers elle cette petite communauté
albanaise du monténégro 7% de la
population qui tentent d'y vivre en paix
car en ces temps difficiles quand le
coeur et du côté de l'otan met les pieds
en yougoslavie
mieux vaut rester discret
une minorité ici nous vivons avec les
monténégrins sans qu'il n'y ait jamais
de problème vraiment cette histoire est
un accident c'est parce que sa maison se
trouvait à côté de l'objectif visé par
l'otan bien sûr c'est un drame n'a pesé
très lourd mais ce n'est pas elle que
les avions bizot mais je dois dire la
plupart ont voté pour milo djukanovic le
président monténégrins et surtout contre
milosevic et son armée fédérale une
armée qu'ils craignent plus que tout
après ce qu'elle a fait à leurs frères
du kosovo
nous avions de bonnes choses de
djukanovic
mais il faut qu'il soit soutenu or au
contraire milosevic et l'armée s'y
opposent l'indépendance l'indépendance
ça serait la meilleure solution reste
comme ça le monténégro pourrait vivre
seul alors que maintenant on vit des
épreuves parce qu'on fait toujours
partie damon de la yougoslavie
ces années là sont catholiques
une minorité dans la minorité qu'on
appelle des indices or l'une des pays
peu plate et balkans mais quelle que
soit leur histoire ils savent qu'en cas
de problème avec les serbes
il serait parmi les premiers à quitter
leurs maisons depuis le début de l'exode
massif des kosovars bon nombre de
témoignages font état des exactions des
forces serbes
aujourd'hui un rapport publié par
médecins sans frontières semblent
démontrer le caractère systématique
planifier des déportations au kosovo et
ce d'après donc une enquête réalisée
auprès de quelques 1500 réfugiés
les responsables de ce nettoyage
ethnique pourraient être poursuivis à
partir de ces témoignages
après la guerre devant le tribunal pénal
international jean michel carpentier
ils sont sept cent trente cinq mille
réfugiés du kosovo qui ont dû fuir sous
peine de mort
de l'autre côté ils sont environ 800
mille kosovars albanais encore présents
dans leur pays
abandonnée aux mains des serbes un
rapport de médecins sans frontières
véritables enquêtes personnalisées
auprès d'un échantillon de 1500 réfugiés
au monténégro permet de mieux comprendre
la cohérence de l'attitude des forces
armées serbes
on a évité soigneusement le terme de
purification ou de nettoyage ethnique
nous parlons d'une déportation d'un
processus de déportation est telle que
nous apparaissent les témoignages la
violence a été utilisé pour contraindre
les gens à partir pour forcer ce qui
était plus récalcitrants ou ceux qui
hésitaient ou traînés à partir il n'y a
pas dans les témoignages que nous avons
recueillis l'usagé systématique de des
assassinats des disparitions et c est
partout au kosovo les mêmes méthodes de
l'armée de la police ferme pour forcer
les gens à fuir les gens sont sommés de
partir
extrêmement rapidement souvent les
maisons sont brûlés derrière et ils sont
conduits vers la frontière donc selon
les itinéraires extrêmement précis pour
tout les gens qui passent en albanie par
des postes de frontière ils sont
fouillés à corps et nos papiers
d'identité sont systématiquement
recherché pour être détruits donc c'est
ce côté systématique qui nous paraît pas
être une improvisation
cette étude fait également apparaître
une forte absence des hommes âgés de 15
à 55 ans une partie d'entre eux étant
tués ou faits prisonniers
d'autres ayant rejoint les maquis pour
se battre avec ce rapport digne d'une
pièce à conviction le pouvoir de
belgrade pourra difficilement rejeter
les responsabilités de cette déportation
sur des dérapages incontrôlés la
campagne pour les européennes avec
toujours au coeur des préoccupations ne
confirme yougoslavie difficile exercice
de style pour robert hue à poitiers le
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
a dû jouer les équilibristes pour
dénoncer les frappes de l'otan tout en
évitant de mettre à mal la majorité
plurielle reportage alban nicosie
thierry breton
d'abord il y a le petit orchestre la
musique entêtante ce décor tout simple
et le public bon enfant acquis d'avancé
cela rappelle une vieille émission de
télévision car ce soir-là à poitiers
c'est en quelque sorte
l'école des fans de robert hue j'aime sa
façon de parler
il ne se passe pas il a toujours le
sourire et l'air vraiment il bloque même
les journalistes robert hue secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste français
robert hue a gagné ce premier pari il
suscite la sympathie souvent au delà du
cercle militants mais sa campagne new
look fait de questions réponses avec la
salle doit composer avec le conflit dans
les balkans
un sujet qui divise profondément ses
électeurs alors robert hue devient
équilibristes ils critiquent
l'intervention de l'otan mais passe en
vitesse sur le rôle de la france
soucieux de préserver la cohésion du
gouvernement
et chacun sait que quitter aujourd'hui
le gouvernement de la france ce
directement mettre un terme à
l'expérience de la bouche rien en france
et c'est tout simplement dire à sarkozy
et bien voilà venez à matignon ça ne
feront pas ce cadeau là à la droite
c'est bien clair le genre de déclaration
qui exaspère les durs du parti rappelant
la phrase de jean pierre chevènement et
j'estime qu'un ministre communiste ne
ferme pas sa gueule il démissionne
aujourd'hui participer à un gouvernement
qui est un gouvernement de guerre alors
là c'est l'idéal communiste est mis à
table mise à mal alors robert hue
fossoyeur ou contraire inventeur d'un
communisme rénover la liste bouge
l'europe voulait illustrer le mouvement
qu'accomplit le parti tout l'enjeu est
de ne pas perdre trop d'électeurs en
chemin la france a condamné aujourd'hui
le coup d'état aux comores les
militaires ont pris le pouvoir cette
nuit il s'agit presque d'une tradition
puisque depuis l'indépendance en 75
c'est le 18e coup d'état qui se produit
olivier carol
les militaires une nuit leur a suffi
pour devenir les nouveaux maîtres hâte
de la capitale des comores depuis
plusieurs jours ils patrouillaient à
moroni à la demande du pouvoir en place
l'armée a saisi l'occasion pour tenter
un coup d'état une opération menée
semble-t-il sans effusion de sang
sans même troubler le calme des rues de
la ville nous avons joint l'un des
officiers putschistes
pour lui un tel coup de force était
inévitable tant la tension était montée
quel était le risque selon vous qu'est
ce qui pouvait arriver
une explosion sociale après la guerre
les roannais les grands comoriens
sécurité beaucoup de morts et beaucoup
de blessés et là on n'était pas d'accord
entre habitants des trois îles des
comores la crise dure en fait depuis
deux ans août 97 la petite île d'anjou
en fait sécession
deux cent mille personnes qui ne veulent
plus entendre parler du pouvoir central
de moroni ce n'est une action militaire
en septembre 97 ni les négociations
n'ont pu remettre en cause cette volonté
d'indépendance
la semaine dernière les autorités
d'anjou en ont demandé un délai pour
signer un accord d'autonomie avec les
autres îles à moroni en grande comore
des manifestations anti anjouanaise ont
aussitôt éclaté
officiellement c'est pour rétablir
l'ordre que l'armée a pris le pouvoir
mais c'est surtout pour écarter le
président comorien jugé trop mou
un président que les putschistes ont
placé en résidence surveillée et qui vit
là le 18e coup d'état de l'histoire des
comores à strasbourg quelques trois
mille kurdes ont manifesté aujourd'hui
dans les rues de la ville des slogans
demandait la libération du chef du pkk
abdullah ocalan affirmant que le monde a
oublié la question kurde
à cause du kosovo l'ancien maire de
blagnac a été condamné à quatre ans de
prison ferme et à cinq ans
d'inéligibilité pour une affaire de
corruption concernant l'implantation de
grandes surfaces en haute garonne pour
ce week-end du 1er mai où vous serez
nombreux sur les routes opération de
contrôle de vitesse près de la rochelle
une opération en association avec les
paralysés de france qui devrait
dissuader les conducteurs françois
privat philippe ritaine un radar dans
une agglomération banal contrôle le
début du week-end près de la rochelle
mais ce soir les gendarmes propose aux
automobilistes en infraction d'éviter
600 francs d'amendé et le retrait de
deux points sur le permis
bon je vais proposer soit d'être
verbalisé donc pour la pression qu'elle
venait de commettre le choix de
s'entretenir avec une personne
handicapée sur les problèmes delà de la
vitesse en agglomération
quelques minutes plus tard rencontre
avec guy paraplégique victime d'un
accident de moto dans des endroits où on
est vachement on a un peu l'impression
qu'on les connaît tellement con durant
une vingtaine de minutes chaque
conducteur pris en faute écoutent
attentivement le récit d'une vie qui
bascule et ses quatre modes coma j'ai
une peur du tout de ma table où c est
comme je vous dis pas la patate hier
pendant seize ans jour pour jour
ça peut ça peut arriver n'importe qui
peut nous arriver après six ans
généralement dans l'avion du passeport
on y brancher quand on les voit
pour convaincre et donner ainsi plus de
force à la leçon une cassette vidéo
présente des accidents graves
il faut négliger dans ce domaine aucun
moyens mis à notre disposition et à être
créatifs pour que les esprits soient
frappés que après tout on trouve en
matière de sécurité
d'autres pistes à explorer que celles
qui ont montré leurs limites jusqu'à
présent test concluant à une exception
près tous les automobilistes arrêtés ont
accepté de rencontrer des victimes de la
route
le traditionnel muguet du 1er mai avec
l'exemple de ce petit village dans
laquelle la capitale du muguet sauvage
didier guyot philippe évêques locaux
étaient bonnes il en va ainsi depuis un
quart de siècle
al'approche du 1er mai les sous bois du
petit village de l'aimant dans l'ain
sont pris d'assaut
ici le muguet sauvage serait une pure
merveille j'ai simplement celui la
maison us de bonne qualité environnement
d'acacia et le muguet parfumé on vient
de toute la région pour en cueillir
c'est un porte bonheur qu'on offre avec
plaisir chez les malades à visite à
l'hôpital
donc je vais leur faire leur petit
bouquet pour les porter mais il ya aussi
les professionnels ceux qui font cela
pour gagner quelque argent yvon est un
spécialiste
il connaît tout des bois de l'aimant le
muguet c'est pour lui quelques milliers
de francs de bénéfices même si ses
bouquets il ne les vend pas cher et vous
demandez combien ça vous fait car une
fois la cueillette terminée il faut
négocier les prix les grossistes vont
venir
et c'est ainsi que l'aimant se
transforme à l'après midi en un marché
au muguet là ça fait trop cher à troyes
france
3 francs la botte de 10 brins de muguet
yvon en voulait 6 il va falloir négocier
le grossiste l'emportent ce sera juste
quatre ans 4au à 4 francs le bouquet un
bouquet qui sera vraisemblablement
revendu 25 30 francs les fleuristes
appel sauna l'or blanc la 88e foire de
paris a ouvert ses portes cette semaine
à la porte de versailles en attend près
d'un million de visiteurs pour cette
vitrine géante de la vie quotidienne
marie-pierre samitier didier rancoeur se
sont promenés dans les allées du salon
et en découvert ces produits
gastronomiques plutôt insolite
il est le seul producteur noir en
afrique du sud c'est la première fois
qu'il vient à la foire de paris
présentait sa récolte et quand on lui
demande le vin français qu'ils préfèrent
repreneur
rien ne prédestinait ce zoulou né au
kwazulu natal à l'est de l'afrique à
cultiver du vin au sud du continent à
mal mais ce bris aujourd'hui 80% de sa
production part à l'export
les anglais sont ses meilleurs clients
ainsi que la scandinavie
chacun ses dix cellular à ça c'est un
vin sud-africain
nous voulons que ce vin soit identifié
dans le monde entier un côté plus
traditionnelle lambres de ce sauternes
dont ses propriétaires produits 6000
bouteilles chaque année j'ai pas grand
chose ce n'est qu'à ma récolte voyez
raymond louis ça sur le dos prenant le
vent père quesnel sauternes et on fait
la foire de paris depuis 1931
dix mille mètres carrés au salon des
vins et de la gastronomie sont consacrés
aux régions de france du pays basque à
la corse
ici on vend des figatelli et du bruccio
du village de la forte parmi les
desserts le passé de chocolat une
ganache du gers conditionné comme le
foie gras
plus loin ce sont les glaces les plus
folles 300 parfum extravagant au poivron
rouge à la tomate au céleri au poivre à
la bière
et puis on fait du fromage blanc fromage
dans l'herbe aux épices 1
fait de safran est sous la menace on
fait du camembert ont fait du renfort
ont fait du fromage de brousse
la fage corps et de match de l'aso
muguet c'est prévu à l'occasion du 1er
mai le premier tour du monde en rollers
ce c'est possible c'est bouclé 20 mille
kilomètres en 3 ans pour ce passionné
qui a traversé les etats-unis la chine
et la russie
fabrice fiorèse est arrivé cet après
midi à paris ravi de son exploit genia
et riche en de l'escr unis il a vu san
francisco et pékin admirez moscou et
signer aujourd'hui fabrice gros ps
patine à saint germain en laye en
banlieue parisienne
cela fait trois ans qu'il tourne autour
du monde partie de san francisco où il
achève aujourd'hui son exploit aux
portes de la capitale
fin du périple débute la nostalgie des
flashs
je me vois dans le désert de gobi ou en
chine où sur muraille de chine
la cfa chez moi c'était génial depuis
mars 96 il n'a cessé de tracts et sa
petite carriole on dise l'unique maison
sur tous les chemins du globe
la muraille de chine où la place rouge
comme décor il aura connu toutes les
conditions nécessaires à une réelle
aventure
vingt mille kilomètres dans les patins
c'est autant de bons souvenirs que
d'instants laborieux vingt mille
kilomètres où la définition d'un drôle
de purgatoire c'est un mélange est
paralysé dans fleur il ya des fois et ça
altère masse et rapidement des fois
c'est vraiment la guérir
vraiment il ya des fausses
position que lui et j'ai connu presque
génial génial on l'aura compris de
belles rencontres un peu partout sur la
planète fabrice gros pèse a toujours
apprécié l'accueil qu'on lui a réservé
aux quatre coins du monde il a attiré la
curiosité de tous et notamment des
autorités chinoises arrêté dans une zone
interdite il s'est vu obligé
d'interrompre sa route durant quelques
jours de déboires en satisfactions il
boucle son tour du monde ou presque
puisqu'il lui reste à foncer sur les
derniers kilomètres vers l'arc de
triomphe point de chute de sa jolie
ballade en espagne cette saisie record
de quelques 10000 fausse lithographies
de salvador dali une affaire qui redonne
vigueur à la polémique sur les oeuvres
falsifiés du peintre surréaliste
salvador dali n'a jamais démenti en
effet avoir signé des milliers d'oeuvres
en blanc musique avec la tournée en
france de yann tiersen celui qui a
composé la musique de la vie rêvée des
anges présente son nouvel album passante
du violon à l'accordéon et au piano
pierre emmanuel luneau de l'escrinet
le monde de yann tiersen et au monde à
part qu'on le dit le titre de son
dernier album ici tout est calme du mois
un apparence
s'exprimer une violence c'est facile en
fin de compte c'est un peu l'heure le
remette con
ça va bien quand on arrive à exprimer
à l'extérieur il est quelque chose yann
tiersen est entré en musique comme on
entre en religion à 7 ans par le
conservatoire plus tard il rejette tout
fasciné par la liberté du proc
aujourd'hui livre une musique adulte
libre de toute influence et de tout
préjugé
comme si je me changeais de personnalité
quand je vais l'instrument à un autre ça
que j'aime bien des fois passer d'un
morceau de violon à c'est assez speed a
quelque chose de très calme au piano ou
auteuil cello ce que je j'aime bien le
contre est ce qu'on fera cela
maintenant ce virtuose de nouveau genre
a réussi à créer son propre univers
univers fait de mules ou dit qu'on croit
déjà connaître et pourtant cette musique
ne ressemble à aucune autre
il avant de refermer ce journal nous
rejoignons à nouveau à londres
etienne leenhardt à londres s'est
produit il ya un peu plus d'une demi
heure une explosion en plein centre de
la ville
avez-vous de nouvelles précisions oui
mais avec la première information c'est
qu'un mécanisme de bombe a été retrouvée
sur place et que nous pouvons donc vous
dire maintenant qu'il s'agit d'un
attentat et c'est le troisième attentat
en trois semaines celui-ci aurait fait
pour l'instant une trentaine de blessés
il s'est produit dans le quartier de
soho qui est en plein centre de la
capitale britannique c'est un quartier
qui est très animée surtout le week end
et le vendredi soir avec une forte
concentration de pub de café il est dans
l'un de ces pubs que la bombe aurait
explosé je me suis rendu tout près parce
que c'est juste à côté de nos bureaux
d'autres les bureaux de france 2 ici à
londres il ya une panique absolument
indescriptible avec des ambulances
c'est un quartier avec des ruelles très
étroites des des ambulances des médecins
un peu partout et c'est dans un pub que
donc l'explosion aurait eu lieu un peu
mou la communauté homosexuelle a
l'habitude de se retrouver
vous savez que les deux précédents
attentats avaient été revendiqués par
des groupuscules d'extrême droite au nom
de thèses racistes et il est à craindre
qu'une véritable psychose s'installe
dans la capitale britannique
dans tous les quartiers à forte
population immigrée notamment des
patrouilles ont déjà été organisées
elles seront organisées à nouveau ce
week-end et une manifestation
antiraciste une grande manifestation est
prévue en début d'après midi demain
demain alors merci tiennent de ces
précisions
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres le
soutien de la france à l'albanie avec
l'arrivée ce matin à tirana de lionel
jospin qui propose une aide économique
et humanitaire supplémentaire lionel
jospin qui est en macédoine ce soir
le procès des quatre hooligans ski ans
sauvagement agressé le gendarme daniel
nivel lors du mondial en juin 81 18 la
première audience devant la cour
d'assises de l'essonne en allemagne se
dérouler aujourd'hui l'un des quatre
hooligans a avoué l'agression dans un
instant la météo laurent romejko puis le
point route de valérie maurice 20h50
quai numéro avec sophie duez minuit le
dernier journal le florence duprat de
master dont il café thé ou café sera
consacrée à la 13e nuit des molières qui
sera diffusé lundi à 20h50 sur france 2
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 13h merci de votre
attention
excellente soirée sur france 2
le temps